Позиції України в міжнародних рейтингах
зросли за останні роки завдяки його політиці,
заявив президент Петро Порошенко на прес-конференції.
- На сьогоднішній день внаслідок зовнішньої політики,
яку я провожу, значно зросли рівень підтримки і,
до речі, і рейтинги. Подивіться рейтинги Світового банку.
DW перевірила:
У рейтингу Світового банку Doing Business, на який,
очевидно, посилається Петро Порошенко,
позиції України за останні роки дійсно покращилися.
Зокрема, за цьогорічними оцінками,
Україна посіла 71 сходинку серед 190 країн
за простотою ведення підприємницької діяльності,
поліпшивши минулорічний результат на п’ять позицій.
Тоді як на початку каденції Порошенка, у 2014-му,
країна ледь увійшла до першої сотні і перебувала на 96-му місці.
Водночас президент не згадав позиції України
в інших рейтингах впливових міжнародних інституцій.
Зокрема світовий Індекс сприйняття корупції,
який щороку оприлюднює Transparancy International.
За цим рейтингом Україна з року в рік покращує свої позиції.
Проте цього недостатньо для країни, влада якої
оголосила боротьбу з корупцією своїм головним пріоритетом,
зазначають в організації.
Приміром, у 2017-му Україна була
найкорумпованішою в Європі після Росії.
Таке повільне зростання у Transparency International
пояснюють браком політичної волі до рішучої боротьби з корупцією,
а також низьким рівнем довіри до українських судів і прокуратури.
За оцінками правозахисної організації "Репортери без кордонів",
Україна з 2014 року поступово піднялася у рейтингу країн
за рівнем свободи преси на майже 30 сходинок.
Втім, краща ситуація зі свободою слова, ніж в Україні,
за цьогорічним рейтингом - у Лівані, Мозамбіку
та Киргизстані.
Гірша - у Бразилії й Чорногорії.
Після Революції Гідності Київ запровадив
низку довгоочікуваних реформ, визнають "Репортери без кордонів".
Однак критикують Україну за недофінансування суспільного мовлення,
вплив олігархів на медіа, а також повільне розслідування
справи Павла Шеремета, якого вбили ще у 2016 році.
На відсутність результатів розслідування
цього резонансного злочину вказують і в Amnesty International.
У своїх звітах і за 2017, і 2018 роки
представники міжнародної правозахисної організації
заявили про тиск і залякування журналістів,
які критикують владу за повільні реформи або політику на Сході України.
Тиску та навіть насильства зазнавали
активісти та члени неурядових організацій, які
висвітлюють корупцію в Україні, констатують в організації.
Загалом цього року таких нападів було задокументовано понад 50.
Позиції України в рейтингу Світового банку
за час президентства Петра Порошенка покращилися.
У цьому твердження глави держави є вірним.
Так само зростають показники країни і в рейтингах  інших світових інституцій.
Однак це зростання відбувається надто повільно,
тож позиції України і після покращення результатів
залишаються дуже слабкими. Її сусідки в рейтингах
- здебільшого країни третього світу, а відрив
від розвинених держав залишається надто великим.